After you decide which model you wish
to implement, it's time to shape it and
learn from it what is working and
what's not.
>> We'll go into the details of how
to track success in the next lesson.
But, it's important to get
the hooks in place early,
so that you can monitor
performance later.
At this point, you also probably
want to track as much as possible.
Think about any actions and
events that you can learn from,
and add them to the tracking,
so that it's set by default.
>> If you have a decent audience,
it might be a good idea to
test your model on x% of your users,
and learn from it.
If you want to learn more about A/B
testing, we've linked to another A/B
testing course on Udacity
in the instructor notes.
In the next node,
we'll provide resources telling you
exactly how to set up
tracking in your product.
We recommend that you follow the steps
now to get things set up early.
If you currently don't have a product
that you can track, then we recommend
reading through the resources to
familiarize yourself with the process.
And then bookmark relevant
resources to return to later.